танки США
руху та ті парфуми будинку кордону на ту opens
сина оборона цінні раз поливання обидва
право кого невинним із заходу не звинувачує
сепаратисти
у середній Україні санкції проти Москви
туди і сьогодні ситуація може його дешати
няша за годинник у холодній провини
юрікова росія
порушуючи ос броня геть і вигляд неприємний
ядерну атаку на варшаву на пошті ми
моєму буду насторожі країни нато
викричати
деталі більше хороший на оружні не було
кен стотт
ми робимо округ які посилати спектр
стримування і стволик для
потенційного агресора серйозно
проблем вірити of pale на сході
україни-русі я та 3 травня сепаратистів я
президент Російської Федерації 146
мільйонів людей і у цик люди та свої
інтереси
образ ворога повернувся на знижки на
східний новий конфлікт між заходом
то сходом вуст роду на первинному результаті
польші
тут вага пакуємо і так мій зал і хитайся
злетіти лиша 2 води наїзди автомобілем
до російського анклаву калінінграду до
руси і розмістю я б дали більше вереск
тінь юнак і з'їхалися Ісусе їй польші
він і хоче самі доброти провладного
стеку клуб this хвалю його не для них цпш
томати збрую в руках стріляють на і
полити а чому суцільним і патроном і до
долі допускають лише від них хто добрий
собою виявивши на уроках ризикові
підготовкою артуру 18 руки
Він один із старших тут хлопців нехай з
як поштою хлопець вона за нашими країнами ми
слабо разу ну там у всьому плані
і см3 спокушаюсь роботи
виправдається і одразу нікуди не знаєш з
чим може працювати замовним рогом на
кожному розі
артур і квінсі тут з гордістю носять
солдатську форму мета дозволена так вже
школах так званих ризикових класах з
втратили поклик ніклас вапняному вухо
ламп хіба чайних школах кілька стиків
класі в уста не 3 роки по два лося
так russia's правді вагони противник
будемо влаштуємо великий ризиковий потенціал
до того що на головній постійну базу
на пошті і як конфлікт треба бути
готовим гадаю росії ясна навіть під
потрібний противник європейському та
світловому у світі польське міністерство
оборони петри мій весь кави класи його
ніку росту і цап досвіду ми школі риф так
хто хоче 8 стати поліцейським тих хто
про кур донний ком багатих то ризиковим
для кароліни з давнім ria почуєш
війська жнивами з ким своєю мої будні я
бачу в армії там ще я люблю адреналін
чохол та було мало я бігала з їх
ріжків та оружня це градусів солдатик
бойовому духу школі рамної шлюбу я на
м'ячик щупі годину на в чайничку на сар
даєте
мани на здаються ж хоче пляшку то
виду бою на випадуть оральні за грози
варшава самий тут cool хату в ucla
даний варшавський факт ризиковий союз
навпроти огуну все будеш великих
очевидно то більше захисту вітру сен
єдиний авіто на не дістати newbies
пікус видно по флангу та розміщення тут
пасти їх весь канатів цін емоцій
і великий content and all та їх моєї but
цю статтю про і символічно
продемонструвати репетуєш вчися вчора
язичок як нас видно по флангу
буду захищена
to 2 of 6 alb defender ну позову тисяч
кілометрів дарина перцевий скит таллін
100 вийти з тоні та політичний курс
тут ви спочатку вже давно
орієнтація на захід членство в нато
вступлю з євро саму ідентифікацію
первинно європейська минуло радянське
c1 знаємо менших crying у Європі а ви в
харчуванні ризикових ви дотки дивитись 2
решітки внутрішнього валового продукту
україни на тупо ви не виділять і на вус
броня
шляху малюк знову 28 досягаєте готелі
естонії це porsche у тебе thirty
командувати силами оборони естонії б
чаю в Росії завантажу тілами району why
you convinced соліста їдуть грузія
збільшила свої скронь та за посадою в 2
кліка разив
на кордон вусі західну Європу на
кордонах застав відвезли твою росіян і
формують нову танку в армію але виду
візі та он і power таїті до скронь їх
структури частини в холодній провині і не
підвищують предками та ядерну з бровою це
гімнастика сура мурахи відносить вже
голова Ольга вигукнула чи то
в естонії у бойовій готовності прибувають
блузку 6 тисяч солдатів його citroen і суть
у роті на естонському кордоні патрулює
територіальні води з протяжного боку
Росія
перевіряти на вигляд рибалок наша бичкова
акваторію волі залучав і кордон чути в
шукали не адепта перед вона її на руку
фальшиво живого тіла розум у продовжу
вуста них 2 руки в патрулювання про
кордону гуміста нарви посилав їм bespeco
держави підкоряються на та кордонах та ми
на продавити ми перчик побачите про
записку дону ціни бачила ніші про
гардунья території нато і каю зберігаються
усі троє людей
трос під уральського союзу нарва то
Івангород розділяв і кульки нинішніх
розділяють кордони нарвали злодії чирикай
естонському місцю івангород права root
російської нападали quit курей дуна за
естонії та Росії до слуг його лапу
вітрина дістати не весь до
such as now оружия не високо мобільник
ядро зроби він і часто потрібно в про
кургана мурахою не на інформ вчи
процесу сидні державу цілих набухаючи
страх русь екскаватор мене в естонців
на сні 2014 руку russian відсилаючи свої
та літній підрозділів крим
он і мити його закуплюсь українське пиво
острів тоді балтійські україни
бояться російських залів інших черв'ячки
солдатик без розпізнавали їх знаки весь
кова техніка без номерних знаків
вона не знає про новий на безтурботний
сценарій піт називаю гібридно вина
праву русь росія
lyvrus з про coordinate продовжують
патрулювання на суходолі кордон
контролю йти ви дубова виходять на
ритку поліцію так чи коптери
микола кондрату ви ж рукам та інші
таксистом у нарві коли на моє пасажирів
слуху і радіо там регулярно повідомляють
проросійськи wynn з чого частіше залітають
в естонський вітринний простяг навіть
близько до ігор одного місця
батах то в нарзі нарика ще естонський і
ряд покинутих на виробляючі кола
ваза нас дуку зайвого будинку культури
його зайнятий bonay стан для таксиста з його
особистою
катастрофічної катастрофічно ситуація
без рубайте
за гломус і носила не місце у 3-му та
мінімально зарплат нім stop the триста
сімдесят євро шкарпетки у містик знайти чий
за крима сир і ткала їх ми коли бату хто
став таксистом би не знаєш про в меншу
роботи держава вставляючи палиці в колеса
новим і правилам і новим ліцензіям і
шкірно знає кішка та грушею
hollywood продали ще один документ
влада планувала видавати ліцензії
вишиті водія мені кицька лоліта і що за
стоєчку йому ви
у багатих urgo вся терпіти даремно що та
російському за межами клієнти туди без 6 в
нарве узо гали мало хто розбавляючи
естонську
мене розуміючи проблем гідну нову
просто особливі складу немає естонської
так я можна і розбавляти і посад і
його вириті червона вуса швидко просто не
хочу проста російською коханою у так
як я км укол це його колега баготу хто
в балтійських краї кабоча я завантажу в
відмінних russian ах та спокої тисячі
струмком вже їх ви просто ти а
паралізувати і в прибалтиці друг і
кримський сценарій у нас стало не до
росії добра цілої кадрової acana хай
за своїми завданнями all його порушується в
період і піднімається в моно inox це
диктатор при владі
у на премію росії шукаю кілька резервний
рік у псковську область
там не даним а я думав до чого треба
прибалтику якось у Росії втягнуті чищусь
така в Росію втягнути або ще щось
таке крим крим взяв якось так залазили
на чоловічки у пропаганда просто від нас
тільки буваю приклеюю платив за вас
ми колон змінюю своєю думкою що до
росії новачок шовен один так поважаючи
алла своїх cool їх вінтажний прогонів так
і зараз на гавань і он і розходяться
9 травня москва червона погано
тисячі солдатику чекою початку за родом
russia's гілку та пара муху над німецькими
нацистами
втомимося рука знову з було ліжку пензлем
ризикових вкрасти їхні традиції рівненських
частиною кулі на купцова так уже приховатись
так сьогодні вона хоче покращити я сяду
акції безсмертний полк темі прадід то
його сестра раз на вигляд його на
в другому святого імені ван і воювала за
рогальський союз 1 чит скарбниці
на фронті тут свою двоюрідну сестру
на зграю кулі знайди на парад настя так вже
хоче шину вати свого про вчора на
черву непогано русь їжі монстру я свою
скронь вміти втомимося рукава президент
путін блазні в модерні зубів армію
особливо важливими для не місто не весь до
з їхніми
та ядерними боєголовками
а такий штанг і росія розрубала
абсолютно нову модель армату
битий коли і тут показав і нато спав
вдарився
серб то молот store радянські символи
даси на прапорах російських обраних
сил кулі на те і ледь йурід нас гостро
поважають правильним, що кремль
втомимося і рукам і ви витрачаєте в богота
мільярдів на новий про скидання ним у
перших це просто досягнення з дуся
знання наших розривних iv росія завжди
славився своїми видихом дні коми і ще у
нас це збирання і гусака цінно шаміль ваша
міць громадян мають знак ще геть і за
розкрадання вони під захистом
якщо за родом сотні тисяч учасники груп
з'явитися в центр безсмертний полк кілька
руки в ту музу снував я голлум очку
ініціативу тепер його офіс але п'ятий мій
Кремль
морщі пам'яті став і страшним народним
руку сюди і vrucica поважається про і вам
патріотизму
особливий бтр у години на правій із за ходом
ні у нас немає порівняння в на знімаючи
страху нове вильні фігурок забудеться
Європа наша україна вини не боїться і на
адже спілкуватися стає то ми вже
вигравав і не раз пари чоловіком ще раз
etna
вона проріз
з так уже про його ризикову карнавалу ш
нову тд udev його кримінальна команда вача
радіанс кого диктатура старовина криті
кіно річкою чарусі дільничний сумують цю
частина європейського союзу і тим самим до
холодну провину радянське рецидиви не
пасує та й мечу сучасний папір поліса
Москви
шеф-редактор у одного з близьких до
кремля години пасив зістригаючи вигляд
поспішних за ременями
ви кінці це дико двір і напевно можна
сказати про дух холодно і провини
повернувся і нас правді ціна то з міцний
і поясними тисячам і чому нині моєму
шоу природу і не куримо не холодно вина
розхиталася акула на матчі нагулу в
руїнах
якщо другові та світловій провини європейська моя
дружина 5 10 лити розділила залізь назви
з 2 блоки з hanoi to захисний та доу
логічно на прикладі me do зубів з
бронетанковим військам це атомний лад
дане шоу сподіваюся лол і шість разів
завантажу означає і 1 1 ядерну з бровою
для гонки us бройлера дядька масу usa
вина прикиньте забрак ло ресурсі
контекст рср горбачов то президент США
рейган завершила форми витрат на
конфронтацію з падінням берлінського муру
завершилася холодно корочанський вина
комуністична розуміння за знав про
краху
тільки руки в потім укол їж не супер
знайти підписав і один з
основоположників тиф русь ця нато з
пробував і стати партнером і
all і для русі c партнерства зграя rusher
у вані i'm crying лиж його з hanowa
блоку
і кіра ніші слухайся Москви тпр прогнути
членство в альянсі одразу станемо нас хіт
натомість стояти і сну ризиковий альянс буду я
у брюсселі новий головний офіс
теперішнє напруга з москвою для нотацій
результат нових загрос
ви вона тебе ковбасить вайшнавами устань і
холодні провини цю дику сотні тисяч
солдатик стояв і зітхнув на кордоні усності
не ядерну зброю гуси ми боялися овали
курячим жіночим союзом на там з
отриманими штатами
до подій and night він просочиться нині
шви кладку тому з чим і моєму праворуч
багатий mo nai ви значущості many more
once or twice сходу Європи налякає на
адже фінал баварської провінції
луї faber пальці та й ким аїжк антип
рука і лося сьогодні до світла, а простіше
буріто силу
за кілька сотників злетіти вже всі
готове для заводу не особливу богу міст розум
був одруженим вартового міст
лиж та кивка метрів алла його роль душі
вагона
весь куб США 1400 солдатик то 400
видаліть ризикову техніку по розвивається
вапняну бази в баварії на премію
подібну європи перед він міст у я початку
операції драгунський wraith
ось вечері чудово ми не подібні до цих полів
право завжди виду ваще
розуму й не так звучить послання
друзям у Європі знайшли hugo естонію ван
і хоче продемонструвати свого його
адже для кого не кожен
полковник майєр
слідом влаштую здати не самі ріканського
риме швидкою висновки на будете про я в
роже sti type of залишалися
російський державний таліби дуже
є знімає де американців за нього
шановний житель Петербург його пара я
проти Росії на підземній
Будівельник роботах у компанії
mannesmann у мене був схвалений сосунки з
росіянами а заразні підірвали ізгоїв на
ручці стрімчак брови не в серці неправильно
на ринг уве площі нас удачі в США
чекають до небагато світлове політики в
баварські провінції
на початку 2017 руку саша хоче parades
ла кувата в Європу дадуть його калугу
бригаду
я напій creed місяця для подібних чола ні у
нато сша думи волосся процес балтії це
польші сорокін шоу шукають довести своє
лідерство на те він і його сили США
хвалити рішення вид права ти
американські назим не весь до авіації обидва
флот на ситний фланг на те ми робу moze
на національному рівні lm та вузла джеймс
з корінними структурами на ту так ми на
вище за попередній нашу тінь з тих члена
альянсу
червоне відьму двох сторін не встигнувши росію
за низьку союзники luna tu
ось так і спосіб ми хочемо і так уже ти
стрибав від того чого ми в чеку ми ж
їж їхню людину альянсу
expect from los в США я дахом носила на
ту
для національно з відомих
страшні провокації
я числа поза кунами тут не подорож до
вибір типу нижній новгород вінчан партії
путіна і засунь єством президент
фонду сиз висловлювання російської культури
за кордоном
причину краї за за ходом вершить
кістковий шов
ця політика поєднувала що цифри гасимо
політика США з інструмент
американську політику інструмент
американського глобального домінування
США дії рублів вуса рахунок закріпить і
свої святого та лідерство своєї святого та
панування наступні альтернативні
центр сили одним з зік їх знай bates та
русь з'явиться росія пельц його в Москві
стріт-арт у групи масивному випалену
до кремля американський робін і в
російському міксері
в США обидва рожні так і по грізного і
підтекстом уралу
діяч до пляшки вдалині
центральний офіс державну міжнародну
медіагрупи Росія сьогодні
владним інформагентство вам супутник 30
мама вам і swits і ширше і трусики baci
не міжнародних шляхів онлайн радіо
the video content
весь до вітаміну супутника вигляді краю пітьми
лаку роль міжнародно кулі т.к. так вже
популістам європі супутник при ділячи я
багата на увагу кожному хто агресивно
виступаючи протесту на ту
антон анімів шеф міжнародним побачила
супутника здається оброблені моїм мечем
встигли на вас пропагандою у
ми вже ніяк їх не нижнього голдмана в
інші ми на вигляд ля йому нічого такого
враховані ви буваєте нас правді у седанки
баби з думав текілу night на супутнику
засіки то в наших ЗМІ задумки і
переважно європейських експертів
європейських політиків європейських житель
еварістті rest там у з таким же успіхом
можна і ваші жителі ваших політики
викликаного чого ти в пропаганді лише й
тому що вони дають нам інтерв'ю з до вже
давно країна там є дивними
то годинником телком за гро словами і в'їзд
вона-то поважає самою історією ок історію
тут на забуття російської держави
latvian а вас не за блок увала сайт
супутника латвійську нову на задок гуппі
відразу буде лінза проти of all євразії
1 місяця до супутника шукаємо російським
змі
визначають баха то у вови путіна прикмет
не будили протилежного від сильва робоча
група на той центр стратегічних
комунікацій так офіційно
називається за заснований кілька місяців
щоб розвінчувати і пропаганду
у фокусі російські змі
і вони стартують вчену службу що хочеш
ніби правової в інформації не винен
якуну і вигадку в цій росіян куди
відновлений захопив геть і намотаєте
показати через kidney публічний суд
come alive богачук ви підходите думка
сфабриковано не праворуч висоти
специфічний народ і до їхньої
пропагандистську компанію пропаганда
прикладі всього знаєте багата здається ртс
часто у катувати експертів і як з року ми
можемо його видною ти джерело переміщень
серйозно поїду на ісу мирним після давньо
виживають повтори не sands атакувати
методи за разок
он і показувати вали краплинки слини
резюме чоботи та все прослухати
зупинити
і різанини акценти в серці для
демонстрації 1 травня тема
їжу міг олег щоб послуга талиша текст
початку складу в міністерстві за
кордон і впораюсь та і спіцина you just
like у вашому фарме ністю його даних.
тримання канал росія сьогодні цілий show
dance is my
столітті моніторі царство його команда була
позов про десяток спину hipster
все просто nike ренату аналізу та пітьма у
нім ми то ви критої стратегії по
парапету істота за допомогою брошур
статей
ерфурт
столиця німецьку воду рідної землі тюр
або населення блузку 200 тисяч
нацу аудиторії орендується репортери
зірвати та фау
місяць цілий модник з офісом у центрі
місця з весни 2015 руку сорбетів оуза
порожні у нову програму
забрак la частий на ній його рубля я
німецька служба каналу росія сьогодні
клаус дітер бем владних solve the fall
взуття хоч і включить її в сітку
мова не дала каналу
майонез по напруженню те з чого формування
у романську думку може бути ширше
малюків 1 їжі на думку
ляканий путін погано росія він не хоче
чхати погано але вам наше право за
папанова ти людям такі продукт а їх не
за інформацією з точкою за русь та
вид політики через c клубу від приховані до
канал ширший і руську агітацію в
німецьких думе вк ах мовляв за брата
часті на не менший від пропаганда
раз якраз через малина відомства про
праворуч у ЗМІ так і дало зали і на
світлом у програмі забрак la части
наїдається пройдусь їм про політику
пиво 1 та ефіру сюжети гості у студії там
відмінний спектор адже протест вправо
екстремісти волоку британії до краю за
біженців
так вже будь in the act та насильства що
до російських німців у нас праведних
темп йому гермес гвалт увальня напав на
літній російську їм до нього і лугу ти
а не валу одні з топ тим на вихідних
богату тисяч людей із рідних
живуть і не матч і не вийшла на акції
протесту на журналісти російської
державного 1 каналу його на поганого такою
полеглим подумавши про цілий потік німецький
адвокат найніжнішим за сильних майданів
подав у позах за розпарювання
міжнаціональні виражені че
критий до передачі голову суддів трубам він
і відразу мило ніжна пропаганда ваша even
ось я всі козаки з брехня і повтори ось
їм russian і лають
russian і лають тему лікар через хто з
тієї power line і можна меншим закидати
з тих хто снопи поза ричать з'явитися та
наше ім'я письменника on the sims c менше
Пухляк подібний образ приймаєте
що не cool emir цілий канал на
mastercook позитивних видів для початку з
товар чує тут strong пропаганда руся я
дуже син мід єс пропаганди
я би сказав на заходить з е3 та пропаганди
олег чим і шановну пропаганду
найбільшу проблему там і нато з простіше
йому ситуацію
оцінку з simplify досі аналізу вата
конфлікт завдання катарального а коли
ними політики bsp як барі не пропаганда
тут вище 1 за статтю дасть силу про сланця
де ми тарусі їм за та витягніть ми
хочемо гостроти глобальну цілу bookvalue
режимі c нормально а думках дати його
ненормальна агресія знаєш що у
скронь йому-то економічному плані
моно робите цим я теж стратегії
їжу surname cm et та повернутий та куліш не
можуть нести кульова вдалині тіматі і на
тому послав вони е100 створ вони обидва скоро
стане ресін солодких місію тему
захисному конгломераті на ту с і c
справді рубаюся аж лихом пропагандою
абакан
на сході України нікого на тикових
нового холодно вина європ тут їжа
страшно
гаряча вина бігу вже заглянув і над
дірці тисяч людей демаркотійна лінійних
сепаратистам це україну you
лінія розколу лише сходом то за ходом
після анексії крима русь е53 мало
ризиковий конфлікт з днями України
суладарі вся кава зубок старовин поспішає
затиснути прямо ним режим потягнемо салладор 1
де старих шахтарських mist
якщо ми на вуличних боях вийшло в моду
форму вати все вже вт блокад не кулер і
у кулачному санаторії нині розмісти все
ситуаційні центри
лискова службу в цій україні тарусі та
служать тут розум коронкової ощадності
українців офіцер дуб в'янучи командиру
ці доручення рудому тисячі сталося за
дубу
квитку сміття зафіксував і кілька
безпілотники
фірма пряма
всі 5 травня маленьких петрівна брокерського
Російської Федерації за безпечний і
ремонт системи газу порожня не стану цієї
піци або ваш телефон на сигнал у Алли
пройдусь їм staged та задута rimonim
режиму тисячі ціна кози для патруль iv 1
лінія фронту вище за кілька хвали news
дівчата
треба q1 збу демків techniques
постриження України то обидва і схеми
лісі ru
дунець у плід сепаратисти ті хто
називається уейну врума жіночу inci
навчають не a pasar від кого ну і ну
скит витрати за ходом по режиму при
на нього дню тут стріляють
мало щодо валин
за п'ять кілометрів вид фронту дачні
поселення Тетяна гаврилова приїхала
сюди кілька місяців тому буна спочивала
сява спиці в зоні бойових дій і тут
ви губку сара дня для тієї ж страх
проханий за чорним гумором та
пустельний супутник ну ось буду ніг 39
уроку провину вразив німців вразивши алого
є українською революційною париже
революцію не переживу артилерійська
снаряд на щастя не коп вона була в будинку
у Чикаго не Тетяна вигляд політикою 1 пак
ласти край вінні тасс повному страху
жити розум
ну і плюс до глав малюю я б сказала
чудовий фінансово в Україні рибний
булавин і а москва так і iv ну його
таєш ще пригадалося залишитися в ж
частини дати за steam переговорів до дому
[ __ ] тис а Тетяна втик розвинутися завивка
після пологів та нсп обережний піст
обидва та сили шити сьогодні і вище на тему
порожню
зафіксувала пун відставай тортури в
порушення рудого тисячі
вусику виду ну не надходить у соледар
українські то російські солдати
фіксують щоб повідомляються пострига че
зубів bouquet de marco тійної лінії так
ми видно в цій сяді світу в витрачу на у
вінні
робота в ситуаційному центрі для
українців
ви пробування ми надавали складно
цьому чим дізнаємося позивачки російської
агресії проти україни складаного було
переломити з психологічного абе в тему
харчування російський солдат а в соледарі 3
мається біля криму
давати нам інтерв'ю на хоче контакту з
українцем а так уже суть ним
приковано вина русі головний аргумент для
край натівський дні європ ви
розміщення пастельних баз альянсу на
своєї території
не мачин це і шукай члени альянсу поки
йдуть ревнуєте основа належного акту
нато Росія
назва жінка агресивну політику
Москви він і не хоче право кувата росію
і завод суттю в документі польова в тому
ще одні великі бойовик ядро ​​зроблено
ви не розміщуйте на кордоні
у крайньому разит упускаються вище куртку
з рукою брутто тіні заходи олені тревал і
перебування це було так би молодий і ціна
bosch про політику захід топтуна то
заруби в Росії 9 словах the zombies and
logic of the cure узами логіку поєдинку
на ту зараз про конфлікт в Україні
альянс на гаїті дуже креативної
interpret ого ти основоположних актів
fardens вгамовує наприклад
обороняється стаціонарного розміщення
збрую їх сил у нових краї нах членах на
там теж забулася і ідея рута тину і
злочинності ви через століття формально не
порошею акт not all і практично c
нехай і новачка злочинність від
practically brains алмаз формально не
матчі на так уже барроу частину шляху та
ротації хоче на повну годину вид права ти
у балті скронь і педро зробимо у porsche
після завершення холодної війни
ним і чино хоче новий ділячи ти більше
грушина а збрую чи то збившого то
бундесвер
якщо у видно не німої чини кіль пензля
штучно скручував ася
т.п. так корей натисни на курсі ми до
зверху чуть збив солдатик d7000
розгром легше відривала людина столиця
дружини актуальним
серпень doors в кінцевому рівні
вестфалії один з найбільших гарнізонів
будда сферу в казармі і ми не роми і
розтушована 20 porsche танкова
бригада сс і вишиває до гор увальня
німецьких сухопутних ризик бойовий танк
тему del поважалося зім'ятим і
співпраці шляхом танки law part 2
викопувати рівня до і модернізму
доступну руку близько сотні так їх ваш
кубовий київ мої дати друга жити а
не машина-то франція хоче розрубати і
абсолютно новий танк на ланцюг йдуть рукою
а до того часу будуть модернізму ті
леопарди а буяк тут кажуть підр шукаю в
цієї кави they and та їхню бойову ідеї
жорг де стоїть один з перших хто карму
і таку ризикову машину та орально
концепція полежав там ще без роботи
leopard 2 sim витри валиком та застосування
за нашими моделями та c абсолютне
загиблими
by шубу і здати є моя принести
бундесвер леопард асем нові боєприпаси
нігтькова броня для хасту вигляд
устричного ops 3 руб у сари дині
прохований комп'ютери покликані центр
ікру вання століття і показую його
жируха low портман і зростання на стати на
випаду потенційну провину в мої будні
бій бачилися з тимоті зате допоможуть
цифрового кру ванінський танк в той же робот
париж і курок і можна значний розумниця
засовувати та боєприпасам за програма
зовсім ехо
для її ударні сили оновить 100
ват і видно в їх російських моделей і
щоб на дати в розпорядженні на те пак
його школі техніка
на те ти і сни на членів альянсу досвіді
виділяла більше грушей на оружні немає
полити його за можу альянс до монстра я
своїми маневром і що приховати дозу
грози збоку русія
ширяє лайки морські натягнеш годинник
в холодну провину вигляд був і сам і нову ос
а не на пікнік іспанії з так вже
підстраховка для crane балтії та знак
того shine the power to its a до більше
адже для купання стратегії що травня
свої на зливки
райський сад води акули мамою мапрі 2 ще
новачків і злочинністю в душу наших
гордонів дельфінів чан більшовицького
морської активності з вітрини та навесні
різак інциденті вагони з окремими випадками
але ще давно ми буду свитками як
російські такі прилад іду за плисти
куди американського скронь у корабля в
балтійському морі може ви нікотин
забезпечення ситуації ки мислить за
побігати і
але надасть валюти правила та інструкції
механізми щоб по парі та ти так і не
без причини ситуації кендіс can obtain
джаз situations
ситуація більш небезпечна ситуації зазвичай
безтурботно вирішити їм чапі годину холодною
війни не було великих воєн в Європі
cool їх добре вина закінчилася а
серійний владний навчався у його славі та
так уже менших місцях після розпаду ссср
був і провини
ситуація нині забрати map ароматом та
значить місця беляші з точки зураби
speck росії для нас у готівкового
скачаної Росії звичайно з для нас воно
більш небезпечно
даний аспект нової конфронтації
накласти так вже ядерно збрую руси його на
частий на нову та військову доктрини для
нато вона завищується за особливим адже для
кого не США так вже модернізує св
арсенал щодо давно американці це
стволи міжконтинентальну ракету
експерти намагаються б чіп уши руется
на балтику гарантії я погана спайка
збоку сша чіпі та а мера коннор мові
ядерну провину за раді з тоні
латви і литви вид по адже у цитати
обами
однозначні так новачок і дипломатично
сформульовані
давалось не моя нових че старих великах
ніж червоних членів альянсу
таллін рига Вільнюс таких важливо повік
лондон берлін че і вашингтон і c я
вважаю одна коротка фраза я копаючись не
принцип 28
за раді. . . знеструмлена вторить підпілля
кадр із сирії
занять бортову камеру та російського
бомбарду вільні до
ми нову осінь русев працював у громадян
scooby ну в сирі вигляд провалу скроні ваппу
вітрині силою to such as але будуємо
допомога для виживання диктатора асада
вояки хоч гравець у московський солдати
будемо туди всі глави мід і без Росії
мер близьким результатом
вершини марлевий путін вирвався з
ізоляції річки упи не всі через конфлікт
в Україні та знову став учасником
переговорів
однак що подув від гри зумер Росії
це за ходом
травня вигляд but also be shy
я всі ми не прозу повз сестру геть у того
а нас правді і збулося, а за астані два
з половиною десятиліття то я не бачу
повії в для пари завантаження на великому
ожив і влади по страшному проти від і
україни конфлікти з і таких
безладну вона найважливішим я конфлікт у
україні у team можна його курити листя в
Москві сьогодні хочемо вживання
заморожені конфлікти
зони пливу в clash не імперії bespeco
адже заходу куритиму іншу і вмс видно
укол ці Москви спортзал державного
спортивної спілки
та сусідні школи номер 2109 суди машину
і клас дайте
молодь хоче побачити і нормативам опіум
gpf перекладин готової до брати оборони
основою ризикового виховання уральського
звузиться було взуття з комусь путін своїм
указом видно виходу на за barum вчиш
кулері будуть забуті віза не пукаю частину
дугу вільно вбивати її в шкіряних у своя
не зіграє до ж анастасія, що c дає
пориву у нападі на жаль ще начальни за
скарби
від усіх ворогів і для хоче з ніші в
армію теж на підлозі для нього папороть
з бутівка у що у нас павана з ти ми ми
пуху ну у росія кожевин багатого керма
терористи, наприклад, у відсік tool
ми таня треба вечерю потрійну джов ти ми
м'ячиком і жовтим і я клайм він так руси
називають ручну гранату
лимонку
у спортзалі вправлення у стрільбі у
porsche з movie сінках лазерних гвинтівок
пір ухта калашників вже вчорашній день
давайте вирішимо втомилися ти воює цифровими
технологіями згубні любила заваруха
так у губ на кут і сили врагом
ну